hoy 11 de mayo expira la vigencia al
llamado título 42 el marco legal que
permite las expulsiones inmediatas de
migrantes irregulares desde territorio
estadounidense con el pretexto de que
suponen un riesgo para la salud pública
la normativa fue rescatada por Donald
Trump en 2020 a raíz de la pandemia de
Kobe 19 y desde entonces ha marcado la
política migratoria de Estados Unidos
sobre todo en la gestión de la frontera
Sur con México donde cientos de personas
esperaban el fin de esta Norma con la
esperanza de poder entrar más fácilmente
al territorio estadounidense para
analizar el escenario que se abre desde
la medianoche de hoy conectamos como
ring Meyer ella es analista política y
vicepresidenta para programas de hugola
una organización líder en investigación
e incidencia que promueve los derechos
humanos en las Américas señora mayor
bienvenida directo América
Hola Qué tal con la expiración del
título 42 cae el argumento jurídico de
que la amenaza a la salud pública para
justificar las expulsiones inmediatas
pero Washington ya anunció que las
expulsiones de las personas que entren
irregularmente al territorio no se van a
detener sino que serán tramitadas bajo
el título ocho que va a cambiar en la
práctica
lo que va a cambiar es justamente
regresar a lo que era las leyes antes
que una persona que no tiene derecho
legal de estar en Estados Unidos podría
ser devuelto a su país de origen o bien
Ahora a México también lo que ha
cambiado es las los impedimentos que
está poniendo el gobierno de biden al
acceso al asilo ahora bajo un nuevo
reglamento cualquier persona que cruza
irregularmente hasta dos Unidos sería
considerado no elegible para asilo
Al menos que hayan solicitado una cita a
través de esa aplicación cbp uno en los
puertos de entrada entonces realmente lo
que estamos viendo Es mover a normas
normales de de volver a personas pero
también muchas restricciones todavía a
poder acceder a la protección en los
Estados Unidos ahora Estados Unidos
anunció la apertura de nuevos centros de
tramitación de demandas de asilo y de
visados en Colombia y Guatemala por
ejemplo así como la expansión a otras
nacionalidades de política de
reunificación familiar ya aplicada por
ejemplo
y venezolanos esta ampliación de las
vías legales es suficiente para resolver
la demanda de personas que quieren
llegar a Estados Unidos
es una aplicación muy importante creo
que en tema de visas humanitarias para
personas de Haití Venezuela Nicaragua y
Cuba son podrían ser 360 mil personas al
año más allá de unas nuevos programas de
reunificación familiar para personas de
Guatemala El Salvador Honduras y
Colombia no obstante Realmente si uno ve
los números de personas que están
cruzando diario en la región los que ya
están esperando en la frontera con
México Estados Unidos para entrar en
Estados Unidos esos números es una gota
a nivel de la demanda que hay y también
hay que Resaltar que excluye estos
programas muchas poblaciones incluyendo
personas de México Entonces es
importante este abrir muchas vías
legales para la migración pero no quita
la necesidad de que algún Alguien podría
ejercer su derecho de Buscar protección
en los Estados Unidos señor Amaya Qué
papel juega la inestabilidad de varios
países de América Latina en este aumento
de las migraciones hacia hacia este al
norte del continente
ciertamente hay muchos factores que
están llevando este bola de personas
migrantes a la frontera incluyendo
política el impacto del covid de la
pandemia en la economía y aumentando
este desigualdad cambio climático
violencia O sea hay muchos factores que
llevan a nivel regional y a nivel
mundial en números no vistos antes en
este en migración ciertamente las crisis
humanitarias en Venezuela y Cuba también
están provocando un mayor porcentaje de
personas de esos países saliendo en
búsqueda de una mejor vida y de
protección
Y es que no solo es América por ejemplo
También en esta ruta o a esta ruta
llegan personas de otros continentes por
ejemplo de África o de Asia Cómo se
llega a esta situación y También faltan
vías legales desde otros continentes
Pues yo creo que lo que ha marcado mucho
la migración en estos últimos años es
que este tapón le darían entre la
frontera de Panamá y Colombia ya está
considero casi abierto es una jungla
pero ya con caminos que cruzan en
promedio mil personas diarias Entonces
eso significa que muchas personas de
África de Asia conocí unos chinos en la
frontera de de Honduras y Nicaragua hace
un par de semanas están usando esta ruta
para llegar a los Estados Unidos
ciertamente el gobierno tiene una
perspectiva importante de que la
migración regional tendría que atenderse
a nivel regional no es solamente los
Estados Unidos país destino entonces
significa que países como México que ha
sido un país receptor de muchos más
personas solicitando protección está
aumentando en ninguna de personas que
están quedando en México Colombia
también tiene un programa temporal de 10
años para personas de Venezuela Entonces
yo creo que esperamos ver cada vez más
programas de acogida para ese población
migrante en la región aceptando que pues
no todos tendrían porque tener Estados
Unidos como destino pero también es un
problema y un fenómeno regional que
requiere una respuesta Regional de
muchos gobiernos sesión de allá por
ejemplo cambiando de temas enciende la
campaña ya de Cara a las elecciones de
2024 cómo se instrumentaliza la actual
ambiente o cómo se instrumentaliza la
migración en este actual ambiente tanto
por demócratas como por republicanos no
yo creo que estamos viendo obviamente
muchos intentos de endurecer la frontera
y limitar la migración incluyendo estos
nuevos programas del gobierno de biden
que realmente van a minimizar la entrada
legal al país de mil personas al día a
través de estas aplicaciones cbp uno
también la presión a México por ejemplo
recibir no solamente a personas
mexicanas sino personas de Cuba Haití
Honduras Nicaragua y Venezuela a México
algo no visto antes de aplicación de
título 4 y lo que era el programa
quédate en México los republicanos
también están usando el la situación en
la frontera como un arma política en sus
campañas cada vez más diciendo que la
frontera está fuera de control eso creo
que es el impulso también del gobierno
de tratar de poner Barreras y
administrar quienes pueden entrar en los
Estados Unidos con el fin de realmente
minimizar el número de personas en la
frontera justamente para fines políticas
demostrar que sí tienen control sobre la
frontera y que sí saben administrar este
fenómeno migratorio regional Mira
analista política y vicepresidenta para
programas de bola Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos con el análisis de Este
título 42 que en solo cuestión de horas
Ya expirará y según lo ha predicho el
presidente Joe biden causará una
situación caótica allí en la frontera
Muchas gracias por atendernos muy buenos
días Muchas gracias Y ustedes
televidentes también gracias por
sintonizarnos no se desconecten que
minutos regresamos con más noticias en
directo a
[Música]